in the 19th century Kong Marx talked
about alienation which is a separation
of being a stranger to something and
you're an alien to something and Marx
said there were 14 a4 Ilya nations in
this culture
one is related from nature well at a
conference dedicated to looking at the
physical and the natural environment we
don't I don't have to say much to you to
show how alien we are from nature when
we're destroying nature itself the
second alienation is some other people
and that means we have less contact we
have less intimacy we have less trust we
have less of a sense of relationship and
that of course as I've shown you leads
to increased propensity to illness
physical and mental we related from our
work a lot of people no longer do work
that has any meaning to them and that
means that and since human beings are
productive creatures we really are
created in the image of God we're meant
to create when we do work that's not
creative that doesn't reflect who we are
that imposes depression anxiety a sense
of meaninglessness and maybe the sense
of meaninglessness we'll want to
substitute that sense of meaninglessness
or that sense of meaning that we've lost
by all kinds of other activities and
then we get all hung up on how we look
or how people feel about us what we can
obtain or we can possess for successes
we can achieve in other words all the
false substitutes which cannot possibly
compensate us for the lack of genuine
meaning and of course what this society
does it sells us a lot of products that
substitute for that loss of meaning in
fact much of the economy is based on a
loss of meaning in our culture finally
and most importantly we become alienated
from ourselves let me ask you a question
here
special hands how many of you had the
following experience that you had a
powerful gut feeling about something you
didn't pay attention to it and you were
sorry after its peaceful you hand up if
you have okay I think the eyes have it
if I asked you the obverse question as
20 people have had a powerful gut
feeling you ignored it and you were glad
about it afterwards
how many would not put your hand up well
I'm not sure I'm seeing very few hands
here
well that means to say now you know what
that you're telling me you're telling me
that at some point in your childhood you
got separated from yourself because no
infant is born without gut feelings
they took infants are totally connected
to their gut feelings have you ever met
a two day old who didn't know how to
express their gut feelings and that
means that in this culture if something
very powerful happens to alienate you
from your true self because the world
couldn't stand who you really were and
your parents were too stressed
themselves to honor and recognize who
you really were just like as a parent I
did that to my kids without meaning to
and then we become alien from ourselves
we shut down our gut feelings and I've
got things are not luxuries you know
they tell us what is right and what is
wrong they tell us what is dangerous and
what is friendly they tell us what is
safe and was dangerous and they tell us
what is true and what is false so Mirena
is from her gut feelings we have no
longer a sense of reality more than a
sense of truth well the good news is the
good news is that human beings can
regain their sense of connection to
themselves just as we can regain our
sense of connection to our nature and
empathy which is genuine human quality
is in us we're actually wired for
empathy even rats are wired for empathy
when you stress that's rats in
laboratory by shocking their feet with
electricity they're more stressed
watching otherwise being shocked than
whenever locked themselves their stress
hormone levels are higher that's our
nature as human beings so contrary to
the myth in our
culture that was separated individual
aggressive competitive creatures grouchy
wired for empathy wired for connection
wired for love right for compassion so
really to move forward all we have to do
[Music]
all we have to do not an easy task but
it's certainly available to us is to get
back to our true nature thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder